it's June 23rd I'm Rob your third string
GS News host bummer i know but hang in
there I got some news coming your way
first up halo 5s biggest expansion gets
a release date not only that the entire
game is free well kinda on jun 29th halo
5s warzone firefight expansion doesn't
just come out the entire game will be
free until July fifth as part of
microsoft's free play days promotion if
you're an xbox one owner without halo 5
it's the perfect time to see what 8
expansions have done and if you like it
during the same window you can buy it
for fifty percent off as for the
expansion it's the medias one yet
warzone firefight includes warzone
firefight a new grunt mech boss called
grunt Goblin the new UNSC wasp three new
multiplayer maps and a whole lot more
hmm that's expansive alright again try
all this next week jun 29th market 2016
marks the 25th anniversary of Sonic the
Hedgehog but what does that mean in an
interview with femi soo game director
Takashi Iizuka said we at sonic team are
developing a completely new game as well
as developing a full movie actively done
by Sony Pictures and animation on sonic
boom further saying the important thing
is not the fact that the series survived
for 25 years but how many games were
developed our goal is to add something
new and overcome any potential hardships
Sega also teased that a new sonic
anniversary game may be on the way and
could possibly be announced at his 25th
anniversary party at San Diego's
comic-con this summer given that the
official Sonic the Hedgehog Twitter
recently talked a little smack towards
the poorly reviewed mighty number 9
let's hope they deliver oh nice catch
Terrance it's official summer is here
with the steam picnic summer sale that's
right it's time to grab that blanket
couple Sammy's and soda pop and head on
back inside to your closest dark room
for some good old-fashioned isolation
let's take a look at some of these hot
new sales
stardew valley for 12 bucks this war of
mine five dollars darkest dungeon for 15
and if you really want to go nuts you
can get deals on Call of Duty armagh an
assassin's creed franchise collections
this steam summer sale runs now until
the fourth of July well that's it for me
no it's not pat your head up and head
for the hills everyone once again the
Skynet corporation AKA boston dynamics
is pushing out another line of robot
dogs in their ongoing attempt to make
terminator a reality that's right it's a
big step in evolution for these metal
monstrosities because now they have
raptor heads oh yeah no big deal just
have a conversation look at it big
fallen on banana peels pretending to do
dishes that's not a coke can that's your
severed head he's recycling Oh still not
on board they dip to black at the end
and then show the robot fighting a human
just saying that's it for the news today
thanks for watching